il incarne un rocker peau mais ce rôle
de composition lui vaudra peut-être
césar l'année prochaine johnny hallyday
est à l'affiché du nouveau film de
laetitia masson love me qui sort
mercredi à 56 ans johnny hallyday qui a
déjà été dirigée au cinéma par hossein
godard ou encore costa gavras a toujours
rêvé d'être comédien michel vial
l'histoire d'amour que johnny hallyday
vie avec le cinéma ne date pas d'hier
enfant de la balle bringuebalé au hasard
des tournées de sa famille saltimbanques
le petit jean philippe smet était devenu
un cinéphile boulimique
avant même de se retrouver à 11 ans
figurant sur le plateau des diaboliques
aux côtés de pierre larquey et de simone
signoret je ne savais pas très bien onze
ans que je voulais faire je voulais je
savais que je voulais faire par rapport
à mes parents adoptifs quelque chose
d'artistique
mais je ne savais pas quoi vraiment ça
mais vu plus tard ça m'est venu vers 14
ans 15 ans le désert détracteurs
poussé par sa tante l'adolescent prend
des cours d'art dramatique au centre de
la rue blanche mais le virus du rock
mais son rêve de comédiens entre
parenthèses
à défaut d'être le james dean français
l'idole de la chanson s'écouler dans des
rôles à la presley héros aseptisé
d'histoire mieze qui servait de prétexte
à l'entendre chanter
mais jamais couru après art ou pour
faire un film d'abord je suivais les
pitchs lui à qui et puis je pense que si
on ne l'a pas proposé à moi c'est qu'on
n'a pas envie de m'engager je ne fais
pas les couvrir
d'abord c'est dans sa quarantaine qu'à
l'écran l'acteur a su faire oublier le
chanteur grâce à nathalie baye et à jean
luc godard
puis dans la seule comédie de costa
gavras johnny prenait enfin des
distances avec son personnage en 1/4
mandé contre emploi avec les années
l'acteur a gagné en richesse intérieure
et son ton juste lui permet de faire
passer des émotions comme dans l'ovni le
nouveau film de laetitia masson une
histoire d'amour impossible mais
peut-être un peu trop stylisé pour être
réellement émouvante
ce film a été volontairement traiter
comme ça c'était une volonté de
de laetitia et nous avons nous allons
travailler dans ce sens heures reste que
johnny hallyday réalise bel et bien au
cinéma son rêve de jeunesse les
stigmates de la vie qu'il porte sur son
visage accroche admirablement l'écran et
c'est la fin de ce 19 ans